refresh entertainment is a privately
held Danish company that manages and
operates the best csgo team in the world
that's a stralla s-- they also own and
operate the blast pro series of events
now so far this year Australis have been
- all to blast events and they've
skipped out on three premier tournaments
that are not blast now this has prompted
a social media conversation along these
lines is this a conflict of interest and
what baring might it have on the future
of competitive csgo
[Music]
so last Friday on Twitter a discussion
erupted between members of the csgo
community at large and the astrology on
ik and it started with a tweet from
Duncan Thorin shields now he noted that
a straw 'less had declined invites to
Dreamhack Dallas IEM city and starladder
and that they went to blast pro series
Sao Paulo in Miami he even implied that
they're putting their own legacy at risk
by not going to these events now the
coach of Astralis sonic did respond
saying that health issues and time
commitments and basically jet lag helped
factor in the decisions to go to those
blast events and not go to the other
premiere turns I reached out to a lot of
the parties involved in this discussion
including refresh themselves and say to
kist who is a big part of this whole
Twitter kerfuffle and I'll tell you what
they told me a little later on but first
we have to address the elephant in the
room the thing that's all over Twitter
and all over reddit is refresh owning
both Astralis and blast pro series a
conflict of interest well no it isn't
and here's why in a conflict-of-interest
scenario there has to be what's called a
duty owed now stay with me here I
promise I'm not gonna go full lawyer a
duty owed basically just means an
obligation you have to a person or a
party that you're legally or ethically
required to fulfill the conflict of
interest happens when that duty or that
interest conflicts with another duty or
another interest you owe to another
party so if you're a ak-47 manufacturer
making guns for the T side and you
moonlight as an m4 manufacturer and
throw some of those to the CTS I would
call that a conflict of interest so
let's break this down really quick
refresh Entertainment has an interest in
seeing Astralis continue to kick ass
they also have an interest in seeing the
blast pro series circuit of events do
well those two interests are not in
conflict if anything they're
complementary refresh entertainment
Australis and especially blast pro
series do not have a duty owed they
don't have an in
tres - any other tournament so there's
no conflict here there is Australis as
the top dog of the csgo world get to
decide where they want to play and when
they want to play now between you and me
I would really love to see astralis play
every single weekend because they're the
best in the world but I don't know man
these guys have families they want to be
home occasionally there's something
called a time zone it's a little much to
ask so they have to pick and choose what
tournaments they want to attend now you
know better than I do that there are a
billion tournaments in csgo we're pretty
spoiled for choice every team not just a
straw Louis have to make these decisions
every team that participates in the
blast Pro Series circuit in 2019 plays
five of the seven events not just a
straw Louis I mean look at Dreamhack
masters Dallas Navi MIB R and Australis
are all skipping now if the idea here is
that other tournaments will be devalued
by the fact that the best csgo team in
the world is not attending them well
honestly I can't disagree with you there
but unfortunately that looks like that's
just the way the business is going to go
I said it before and I'll say it again
I'd love for Astralis to attend every
event but sometimes it's just not
physically possible now my hope is here
and call me a little naive that this
competition for teams will actually help
make all of these tournaments better
they will have to compete for who gets
to compete at their tournaments so maybe
they'll step up I don't know their
hospitality game or stuff for fans to
attract more teams to their events maybe
it'll be a net positive now saying that
I know that budgets are not infinite so
they can do what they can do I mean hell
there's a reason teams like to go to
these blast events there was an alleged
budget for blast Copenhagen 2017 that
was made public a while ago and in it
the numbers allocated to hospitality are
off the charts people get treated really
well at these events so even if you as a
viewer are not loving the experience you
can bet the players are now I told you
earlier in the video that this whole
thing kind of popped off on Twitter last
week and a big part of that was Matt's a
to kiss trivet now you know him as a
csgo broadcast personality but he seemed
pretty put off by the whole thing
at least on Twitter so I gave him a call
while he was hauling his race car across
Eastern Canada to get his thoughts on
the situation
I just wanted to get your take on that
whole conversation last Friday I
understand the basic issue of astrology
so far this year has declined to go to
three premier tournaments and they're
obviously doing the blasting whether go
to five blasts this year I wanted to get
your perspective on why this is a bad
name yes I was kind of insinuating that
there's potential conflict of interest
certainly there is a conflict of
interest you can argue when they're
playing on event home by the same
organization but I think perhaps even
more than that and if refresh on them
and you know conveniently there's a
number one team in the world if they
skip other event d legitimizes the other
event which can certainly destabilize
sort of the market right now again you
want to call it that before the ce o--'s
can't say that a we don't have the world
number one in our event sorry and then a
sponsor says well you know to them
another matter they want the world
number one that it okay I'm a
competitive it's a Gertie in the format
that they want to go with that in so
there's a chance that you know refresh
could be pulling just in little ways
little little strings attached that that
would favor them in the long run
marketing lines serve last Road issues
and I I don't know that there is
anything going on but it's a possibility
and if we don't make that clear and if
we don't hold them accountable then by
the time we do by the time it's notice
it might be too late to play devil's
advocate every team that sign up for
blast is going to go to five events
right so that does include your mi BRS
base plans and we saw for Dallas it
might be our nabi and the straw all
declined those invitations right so it
may just not be an astrology here I'll
come back to the point of saying I don't
mind these teams are picking and
choosing and in the case of a Charlotte
and everyone else that's fine except you
can't constantly be favoring one and the
problem with donek is that every time
it's brought up or hinted at or perhaps
suggested as the case before and often
does he never answers it directly he
always as well we're skipping okay we
know you're skipping event
maybe we need sort of a mission
statement from a straw list maybe they
need to be more fun about the one's
gonna be skipping and why or you know
I'm still going to be skipping all of
the Grand Slams again it's just
something seemed fair and cleared other
organizers and
it does certainly a theme play with the
fishes do you think that this could
force some positive change like if blast
is coming along and they're being very
Sharkey about their business and as you
say scheduling things over other
tournaments and doing the the two day
thing and spending all this cash do you
think that could positively affect other
tournaments insofar as the other
tournaments would say well if we want to
pull people away from last you know
we'll step up our game in various ways
for the other events and sure maybe
blossom sit back and say well we don't
care haha we've got it right I'm not
saying that's wrong I think there are
doing they are doing some great things
again for fans in the arena it's
probably one of the better events to
attend for team treatment it's great
that's awesome that's good to raise
those standards if we can if it's just
that if they are gonna try and push and
they are gonna try and create some sort
of that I won't use the word exclusivity
strictly because I don't know that's
what they do but I Legion let's say
within the teams well they need to honor
the competitive it's Agri teeth at we
spent years trying to create I also
reached out to refresh themselves and
their CEO and Founder Nick Illini home I
do hope I'm pronouncing your name right
sir got back to me really quickly on a
tight deadline so I do appreciate that
with some answers I'm gonna share a few
of those with you now now I asked the
simple question within refresh is there
a declared advantage financial or
branding or otherwise for a straw 'less
to attend blast Pro Series events the
answer they gave me back was simply that
those two entities that is blast Pro
Series and Astralis are run as
independent entities with independent
decision-making processes they noted
here that Danny that's Sonic the coach
of astralis is the one who decides which
tournaments to attend I did already
mention this and Sonic said it best into
his tweets but part of the
decision-making process here for him is
obviously how far they have to go some
health issues with device you know
changing time zones how long they have
to stay somewhere and yeah of course who
treats them the best and who is the
biggest prize pool I'm sure factors in
as well now there were some allegations
made on Twitter about an alleged revenue
sharing process within blast pro series
between the teams of the players and I
didn't know anything about that so I
asked refresh point-blank if there was
such a process put in place they said
simply we do not comment on our
agreements of contracts with teams and
organizations
this is a general policy but what we can
say is that all the teams in the
tournament are on equal terms so take
from that what you will
I also ask them point blank some people
are implying or outright accusing
refresh of fostering a system where
there is a conflict of interest in your
view in refresh is view is this true the
CEO and founder of refresh got back to
me saying foul play of any sort or kind
would be risking the players careers the
investors funds and/or the organization
as a whole in other words it was an
unequivocal no I also reached out to the
csgo Players Association to see what
their take on this whole thing would be
now sir scoots did get back to me saying
that their communications guy was on
vacation and they probably wouldn't make
my deadline so no bad on them now they
do get back to me with something
interesting I will be happy to update
you guys now guys I already know you're
gonna flame me for this in the comments
section so don't even stop typing while
you listen to this but just so you know
this is my opinion and you're free to
have your own when it comes to refresh
owning and operating both Astralis and
blast Pro series you can call it
anti-competitive you can call it
monopolistic if you were so inclined but
don't call it a conflict of interest
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]